-Our first guests tonight
are the talented
and award-winning actors who
also star
as the Pearson big three
in the hit series
"This Is Us."
The sixth and final season
premiers Tuesday, January 4th,
right here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the show
Sterling K. Brown,
Justin Hartley, and
Chrissy Metz, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello.
-Welcome.
-Hi!
-Thank you.
-Now, I want to start by saying
happy New Year
to all three of you.
I mean, I think a lot of us had
maybe grander plans for
New Year's this year
before things maybe turned
a little south
in regards to COVID.
But what did you guys
manage to do?
Chrissy, I know -- Did you end
up doing the Rose Parade?
-I did.
I hosted with Mario Lopez.
And I had to be up at
2:00 a.m., y'all.
So went to bed at 7:00 p.m.
I was like, "I don't even know
which way is up."
But, yeah, it was a great time.
Wild but great.
-Why do you have to wake up at
2:00 a.m. for a parade?
-Well, "A," it starts
super-early, right?
There were people --
I'm not kidding --
camped out in
air mattresses, y'all.
They were sleeping on the road
on air mattresses.
But hair and makeup --
women take a little long --
You know.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Alright.
Well, worth every second,
I'm sure.
And, guys, as much as
I want you here in person,
I'm happy that we're taking
the safer path forward,
because you're precious
cargo right now.
You're filming the last season
of a beloved show.
And I have to ask this question.
Did you know -- Did the three of
you have any sense
when you filmed the pilot that
this would be the hit
that it has turned out to be?
-No, I think -- I mean,
I'll speak for myself,
but I think everybody
would agree.
I don't think you can anticipate
something like this.
I knew that --
And I've said before,
I knew that, you know,
when I read the script,
when I read the pilot,
I knew that it was great.
And then when we shot it,
it felt wonderful.
And then I saw it, and it was
the best thing I'd ever seen.
But that doesn't -- that doesn't
necessarily guarantee
that you're going to captivate
an audience, you know?
So -- And, by the way, this
thing, you know,
became a smash hit,
you know, ratings-wise
and things like that, but the
way that it impacts people
in their everyday life
is just something, I think,
beyond anything anyone could
have possibly imagined.
-Yeah, I mean, I read it right
after I finished with
my Jacksonville condom.
I didn't know that
was the name for it,
but then now that I know...
So, I finished with that
and I read it and I was like,
"This is really good," right?
[ Laughs ]
It was awesome.
I was doing "O.J." at the time.
I read it.
This is the best
network-television pilot
I've ever read.
I looked at Paulson, I said,
"I think I know
what I want my next job to be."
She was like,
"Go get that [bleep]
And it happened.
It worked out
in such a beautiful way.
We all met each other.
I remember the first table read.
And I was sitting at the table
and I was like,
"I think we got something."
I remember seeing Chrissy,
Justin, Mandy, Milo,
like, everybody, and I was like,
"This feels right."
And the world said,
"We're here with you."
-How soon into the first season
did you start hearing
from friends and family
about how much
this show was
resonating with them?
-No, just out of the gate,
really.
I mean,
first and second episode,
they were like, "What is this?"
You know?
-People were like -- people were
like, "Can I borrow money?"
Things like that.
That's when you know that
you're on a successful show.
-Yeah, that's a good sign.
When people start asking for
money, you're like,
"I think we got something here."
-I had a cousin text me
after Episode 4,
which I think is the pool,
first episode with
the kids at the pool.
And she said, "Sterling" --
She goes, "I know you had
a really good show
with this last thing,
but this show right now
is like church and therapy
and entertaining and healing,
like, all in one."
And she said,
"I think I see myself
in your sister,
in your brother, in you."
Like, when she
hit me with this --
and it was like
a four-minute message --
that I knew it
was touching people
in a way that we
hoped that it would.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-Do you feel like
you've come to terms with
the fact that it's ending?
-No.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-We're all a little different.
We're all a little different.
I always say,
you know, I'm trying to,
and how I kind of
wrap my brain around it
and prepare myself for it
is just to remind myself
of the privilege of having
something come into your life
that you will
miss beyond belief.
A lot of people don't get that.
And we're all very lucky.
-Well, yeah,
this was my first job,
like, my first real job.
I'm like, "Wait, this is great."
-They're not
all like this, Chrissy.
-They're not all like this.
So what the hell
am I going to do now?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it was an endless tour
of guest spots
for your boy
before not too long ago.
I think that I'm happy to be
going out in a time
where people will still be
missing us rather than like,
"Oh, is that crap still
on the air?"
Like, I think that's the thing
that I feel good about.
I will miss it.
I will miss the people.
I will miss the story.
But on a bigger level, all good
things must come to an end.
And I feel like
it's still a good thing,
and that makes me happy.
-Yes.
-Now, of course, your goodbye
will happen, you know,
a few months before
we see the final episode.
Do you have a sense --
Who do you think
amongst the three of you
will cry the hardest
when you film
your last scene together?
Sterling, it looks like
you're pointing at me.
-I know.
-It's you, Seth. It's you.
-I'm pointing at Seth.
I think Chrissy Metz.
Like, everybody always
acts like it will be me.
And maybe there's debate
to be had,
because we have -- My sister
and I both have loose ducts.
-We do.
-But it's probably
going to be my sister.
That's what I would say.
-I mean, here's the thing.
My emotions
are always right here.
They're ready. They're ready.
-Yeah.
-That's good.
You're a great actor.
You know, it might
actually be you, Seth,
because a lot of people
may not remember --
Well, maybe they do.
You know, it's
the big four right here.
-Yeah.
-That's right.
-All four of us are
"This Is Us" cast members.
-Season 1 right there.
-Season 1.
I had a cameo Season 1.
And I think it speaks to
the fact that no one knew
how big a hit the show
was going to be,
because if they had known,
you would have gotten
a far bigger star.
[ Laughter ]
You couldn't even get
the 11:30 NBC host.
-Dude, you were perfect.
Look, all of the work that
you've been doing
at impression camp
is really paying off.
-Thank you.
-I'm so impressed.
-I just wish we could have
used it before, yeah.
-I will say,
you know, again, that's like
five years ago now that I did
that cameo in that show,
and it's led to no other work.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you're doing alright.
I think you're doing alright.
-That's true.
I'm very busy, Chrissy.
-That's right.
I have so much more
to ask you guys.
We'll be right back with more
from Sterling K. Brown,
Justin Hartley,
and Chrissy Metz.